accordi we had a question come in
earlier from Twitter it's a lady named
XE and she's from Australia I believe
and she says I would love to see
interviews or discussions on developing
secondary characters so any thoughts on
developing secondary characters well
your calf size is always a concern
because you have to give each character
enough real estate in your script to
create enough moments emotional moments
that the audience can relate to and
identify and connect with and secondary
primary supporting if you choose to have
a character that you're gonna develop
you can arc them out in the same wave
like what is the beginning middle and
end of this journey of this character
I wouldn't get too concerned with theme
or how they relate or whatever but if
you're trying to develop any character
you want to be like well what is there
you know do you have enough scenes where
the audience can relate and are they
going on an emotional journey an
interior journey an external journey
whatever the combination of both but
it's it's the same you build it the same
way as any of your characters you you
want to create enough moments where the
audience can see themselves so it's
plausible emotional high stakes stuff
where the audience can see themselves
reflected and they identify and they
sympathize so it's the same things
that's how I look at everything I don't
get caught up in in like formulas as to
where things are supposed to happen in
stories I think it's mostly you want to
focus on you know you and I don't think
there's a lot talked about with
character so it's a very good question
but mostly it's it's the screenplay only
has so long you only have two two and a
half hours to go right or something like
that hour and a half and you want to
have as many moments because a
relationship is defined by the volume of
moments
that we have with the person if you have
coffee with somebody once a year then if
they pass away you have a you have one
kind of emotional response you have
coffee with somebody every day out of
the whole year that's gonna hit you more
so in a script if we see that secondary
character or any character and we're
able to see them different contexts go
through different things and there's a
greater volume of access to them and
different in different in different days
different times different locations
doing different things and bouncing
through this plot that's that's why cast
sizes are small that's why Casablanca
there's basically it's a story about
three people that's why you know Harry
Potter's eight movies basically around
three people really around one guy
there's three people I mean there's
other characters but but we we are not
asked to connect with a bunch you know
you know when you have something longer
like Game of Thrones you're able to
connect with more people because we have
more there's more real estate but that's
only because there's more real estate
and that's how we find our way in to the
main character but still there's only
there are a few there that garner our
most of our attention
hey everybody James coming breasts sack
here and I am SuperDuper excited to be
doing a master class with film courage
on the 22nd of this month we're gonna be
talking about all things horror movies
how to get a horror movie up what little
tricks and things I've learned in making
movies and really I'm just going to be
answering a ton of questions so I'm
excited to see you all there hope it's a
good night I think it's going to be
awesome